time now for morning rounds with CBS
News chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook and CBS News contributor dr. Tara
narula this week Congress finally passed
a spending bill authorizing 1.1 billion
dollars to fight the Zika virus it comes
after nearly seven months of debate
during which some 19,000 people in the
US and puerto rico contracted the virus
it's also about eight hundred million
dollars less than President Obama
requested back in February John how's
this money going to be used well lots of
things most immediately the vaccine
development because in order to go to
the next phase the phase two they
they're out of money so they need this
desperately they need to figure out
better testing I was just speaking to
Tom Frieden head of the CDC he said we
really need better testing we need to
figure out better ways of killing these
mosquitoes and then we need education
well up next deadly air pollution will
this week the World Health Organization
released a report detailing the health
impact air pollution has on the global
population it estimates that ninety two
percent of the world's people live in
places where air quality is poor they
also estimate that at least seven
million premature deaths a year are
attributed to indoor and outdoor air
pollution now the report calls air
pollution the most serious environmental
risk factor we face John they call this
the invisible killer it is an invisible
killer and believe it or not it
contributes according to the wh 0 to
about a third of deaths from stroke COPD
which is a form of chronic lung disease
and lung cancer and up to thirty percent
of deaths from heart disease so this is
not just a theoretical problem that
could affect us it's killing us now tera
they looked at the whole world in
analyzing this data I mean how did
countries with large populations compare
right so it turns out that the air you
breathe the quality of it in large part
depends on where you live and there is a
big geographical difference depending on
what country or what continent in this
report they found that countries with
large populations China India Russia
those populations had very high death
rates per capita in
addition ninety percent of the deaths
from air pollution are occurring in low
and middle income countries in
particular regions like Southeast Asia
the western Pacific and the eastern
Mediterranean those are areas that have
very poor air quality in terms of levels
of air pollution and also very high
rates of death from air pollution well
John 194 member states belong to the
World Health Organization what are they
doing to really impact well then come
out with this road map last spring and
then they have other action plans so
basically the whole world has to get
together and figure out this is
affecting all of us now there are of
course things that everybody can do in
governments can do clean energy of
course renewable energy hydroelectric
solar wind that's really important but
also and this is interesting the WH
eight points that wh 0 points out that
billions of people around the world use
cooking stoves at home that caused a ton
of pollution and there are ways they're
there ways now that are not that
difficult to create clean cooking stoves
and this could make a huge amount of
difference so people think it's a thing
that governments can do know there are
things that you can do individually and
people can contribute to that kind of
effort moving on flu season is just
about upon us so it's time to think
about getting vaccinated the CDC has
just released vaccination statistics for
last year showing an estimated 144
million Americans got their shots in
2015 that's about forty five percent of
the US population down around one and a
half percent from the previous year John
what sector of the population is most at
risk here well we always talked about
kids people especially children under
the age of five but especially under the
age of two the elderly which is
considered 65 and over pregnant women
and also people with chronic medical
conditions but in addition to that the
CDC talks about people who are in
chronic care facilities nursing homes
and American Indians and Alaska Natives
really yeah dr. narula what would
specifically how do these vaccination
rates affect children right so well the
good news is in 2015 and 16 the
vaccination rates for children stayed
steady in comparison to year before
around fifty nine percent the bad news
is it's only fifty-nine percent that
means about forty percent of kids are
not getting vaccinated
in addition it changes as the kids get
older so from ages six to twenty six
months to 23 months about 75% of kids
are getting vaccinated that drops off
over the next 10 or so years so that by
13 years old to 17 the rates dropped to
about forty six percent this was
interesting the CDC and the American
Academy of Pediatrics is not
recommending the use of nasal spray
vaccine yes to the dismay of many
parents I'm sure what's that going to
mean to the numbers do you think well
there is concern by the CDC and public
health officials and rightfully so I
mean no parent wants to watch their
child be tortured with a shot and the
nasal flu mist was very popular about
one-third of the vaccinations given to
kids were in the form of the nasal flu
mist but what they found is it really
was not effective over the last several
years and so now they are only
recommending the shots and I think the
important thing as John mentioned kids
are very vulnerable to this and so while
we think of it as being in acute
self-limited disease process it can
cause serious complications 20,000
hospitalizations a year for kids a
hundred deaths a year lost school days
lost workdays really important for
parents to vaccinate I was reading that
it was the strength of the nasal swab
and in in particular there are a lot of
adults who opted for that option right
and what they don't really know why
exactly it didn't work but it really was
not effective for the last several years
okay dr. Jon LaPook and dr. Tara
noorullah we thank you for being with us